I see Ron as a leader I see Ron as an
executive I see Ron as somebody like Ron
icy run as a person who is a great
project manager what happened on Ukraine
I think he's such a leader why the hell
did he sort of change his position on
Ukraine he's got three different
positions on Ukraine but that part Rudy
I would say I don't know so so uh he
becomes an isolationist to suck up to
Tucker Carlson and then he becomes a a a
a Reagan Republican so you'll call him a
flip-flopper is what you're oh I'm
saying it's a dangerous tendency don't
go uh you know don't you know politics
is not a game of love at first sight
you don't get to know somebody he could
be a great candidate he may not be you
don't know that he shows some very good
Tendencies and he shows some very big
weaknesses that's flipping around on
Ukraine was very dangerous so flip-flop
is what you're saying that's the word
one time he's an immigrant but in
English language let's see if that's uh
him yeah well let's see that if that was
a mistake I'm willing to say he's a new
time candidate
uh we don't know we do not know how he's
going to Bear up
under running for governor of of Florida
and running for president United States
yeah it's like running for school
president and then running for a major
role I don't think there's any dispute
or I I wouldn't disagree with you there
but I would also I've seen people who
were great candidates Statewide who
totally fall apart as presidential
candidates and I'm not going to say he
will but he's I'd be careful betting the
whole thing on him because he's shown
some Tendencies some weaknesses
if they are really weaknesses that will
he won't be there at the end as many
front-runners went out there at the end
so
I'm not even sure he'll eventually be uh
Trump's major opposition I can tell you
Trump will be there at the end he owns
40 of the party
you also got to be careful how bad you
go after him because then you won't be
able to win
you've got to run as a as a candidate
running against it
yeah it's great to bring new people in a
bit of a fantasy also
the only person that's been able to
bring a lot of new only two people have
brought a lot of new people into
politics since Reagan
Obama
Henry and Trump trump won the first time
with new people
so
we got a few people here so I don't know
if if that who was the first Clapper
who was the first Clapper can you okay
where are you sure I'm not sure you win
elections when I when I ran for office
which is which is ages ago you won by
going to the middle
there were the Liberals the
conservatives and then there was the
middle and I won uh being mayor in New
York by going to the middle I had a win
on a democratic State I don't know if
you can win that way anymore I don't
know if there's enough of a middle I'm
not sure you might be able to but I'm
not sure that going to the middle
you lose your base
and here's what I always advise Trump
I don't care what CNN says about you I
don't care what MSNBC says about you I
don't care what the Liberals say about
you is not going to hurt you
when I start seeing your base turn then
we start to worry
because you can't exist in politics
without a solid base any longer that's
what that's what Biden has for sick
reasons and that's what uh Trump has and
that's why
they may be the two most dangerous
candidates you you may you may only be
able to win Now by appealing to your
base and bringing them out more than the
other guys or just plain cheating
that's another way to win
yeah and don't discount that Mr Meyer
um we've asked this question repeatedly
but I would love to get your take on
this but is there any chance that you
see if Trump gets the nominee him uh
pinning
Governor DeSantis as his running mate he
can't they're both in the same state one
of them would have to move out of
Florida
you uh a president and vice president
can't run if they're residents of the
same state paid 7.93 you didn't read
that up to 600.
I'll do better but I don't know I don't
know that either one of them would be
the right vice president but if he could
if he like let's say he really wanted
him and Trump re domicile to New York
let's just say it would depend it would
depend a little on on the primary and
how how strong uh Kamala Harris started
the Democratic primary looking
Invincible right she beat The Living
Daylights out of Biden in the first
debate by the second debate Tulsi
gabbard had totally ripped her apart and
uh proved that she's one of the silliest
people ever in American politics so yeah
what do you think Dave it would depend
on how good a candidate is well it's
interesting because if I'm getting this
right the two biggest criticisms of
DeSantis seem to be that he had a shoddy
book launch which okay let's say that's
that's kind of right which again got to
number one on New York Times bestseller
as as much [__] as that thing is you
can tell that they left my last book off
the list
um
but so he so he okay he screwed up a
book launch let's say and let's just say
everyone in this room agrees with that
and that he hasn't been president before
well most presidents haven't been
president before and I don't know that
you can blame the guy for a book launch
so I haven't heard any real criticism of
the guy right what did it say about the
Ukraine flips okay so all right that
that I would count as a criticism a
little bit of a flip of slipping on a
very important subject that you should
be prepared for if you are a
presidential candidate so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]